uh speaking of Chicago
your friend Kanye man you guys have
Classics together yes uh
uh I he's my favorite artist of all time
he's up there all his albums are up
there you see the little bears yes sir
have you spoken also one of the greatest
artists of our time have you spoken with
him that's the Ty Dolla Sign any of this
craziness has been going on I have not
got a chance to speak to him now
um I feel like you guys are genuine
friends is that safe to assume yeah for
sure one bro
um you know I feel like
Kanye at times says things that
probably
I feel like the bigger Point gets lost
in some of the delivery that he'd be
saying
um would you what would like would you
say based on some of the narratives that
are being painted about yay some of the
anti-semitic [ __ ] I feel like you know
him better than most of the people that
are speaking about him
I would say he's a great guy I would say
he does what he wants there's got to be
something that he's you know trying to
get across for whatever he's doing and
at the end of the day he's a great guy
so we love Kanye and you guys have
Classics together yeah for sure 100